Mr. Momiyama:
Yes, it's fun. Mr. Momiyama, what's
wrong? No. However, Teru seems to have a tendency to get sick when he engages in cheerful activities like this.
I'm an indoor character. I'm an
indoor
character. Sorry, I'm going to take a break.
Hmm, I did
n't know that
Mr. Kamomiyama is an indoor character. I'm sorry, but I'm an indoor character. I'm
really sorry. I was going to thank you today, but
because of my disgusting constitution, I'm sorry.  Now that
I've let you down,
let's bring up a funny topic.I went back to the nurse's office, which had been a mess, and Tokihi
came in.I
thought I'd cheated on her, so I took it.  It's because of
me that I broke it, so there's a cautionary tale that doesn't exist
all over town. Don't try to take advantage of me, even if you're bad at that story. You
always
want to live like that. I want to be unharmed and become the wind.